thank you
[Music]
so we're going to talk about the state
of Marvel phase four
I'm just kidding yeah a little bit Yeah
well it's like where would you want to
go for it it's kind of phase two is it
the Eternal phase four I don't know man
when are you gonna do your patreon video
where you walk everyone through the
timeline of Marvel yeah you should do
that now actually yeah right now so
right now right now right now all right
cool yeah so what was the first movie
The very very first movie that set the
whole thing off 2008 was
Toby Maguire Spider-Man
phase one or what the phase one in the
MCU yeah yes it's phase one see phase
one and the MCU everyone knows Iron Man
right all right well cool what's the
next movie you [ __ ] after Iron Man one
yeah Iron Man 2.
I don't know if that's true or not
it could be it could be wrap it up
already dude come on give me harder
questions are you kidding me all right
all right cool boy
um yeah what happened [ __ ] Shang Chi
dude
and to be fair actually it's easier to
say Iron Man 2 versus [ __ ] The
Incredible Hulk with Edward Norton that
nobody actually it was counting it in
the cinema can you give us the can you
give us the actual that's such phase two
[ __ ] dude all right man go ahead go
ahead thank you uh Iron Man 2 then Thor
then Captain America the First Avenger
then Avengers right and then Iron Man uh
three after that which was a garbage
shitty what happens after that so I like
that they painted because you know that
you end up having Civil War so they
painted the first leader a couple movies
down the second leader and then now what
happens so then after that Thor the Dark
World which is a piece of [ __ ] movie yep
everyone agrees everyone agrees [ __ ]
either then Captain America Winter
Soldier everyone liked that movie I saw
that one I like that one that was good
that was good that was a good one then
Agents of Shield which is the TV show
nobody curious don't get the [ __ ] that's
a part of it yeah then Guardians and
then Age of Ultron which is a piece of
[ __ ] garbage tier Movie Trash movie
everyone agrees trash but still fun
which is the one that Idris Elba dies
but it was way later that's what I'm
talking about so let's keep going so
that's that's literally like Infinity
war end game [ __ ] so that's probably
before then that's not you're in phase
one dude that's what I'm talking about
too all right look my point is because
unfortunately we still have to catch
Bart up but the most of the audience is
caught up I already know about so we're
not gonna read Bart I already know about
the whole edges Alba what do you guys
think of the state of the Marvel
Universe right now so we've been in
phase four for like a year and a half
that's a start uh start in January 2021
with one division on uh what's the
latest one is it Doctor Strange too
because I just saw that one it is
actually technically four that came out
yesterday or two days ago what'd you
think of uh Doctor Strange Joe I hadn't
even seen one but I saw two and I was
like what's happening because I don't
know who this girl is
I tried watching Doctor Strange I don't
even know who the [ __ ] he was first one
the first one the first one that's when
they introduced it to you who is this
guy well tell you if you just shut the
[ __ ] up we're getting there now follow a
movie if it's literally like this
[ __ ] another world
good surgeon beforehand I'm like what
where the [ __ ] are we I was like what is
he imitating such an oversimplification
I'm embarrassed everywhere this guy's
trying to explain the plot of infinity
I tried to watch Godfather I was like
bang bang
what's up buddy that's it that's the
whole movie
why were there so many Italians hey get
the cannolis that's the whole movie
I just don't think you like fantasy I
love not hey fantasy
I remember I remember early JK days like
we're just talking about movies that we
like and then we had like a [ __ ] one
hour discussion as to why like fantasy
sucks and I'm just like why why does it
suck it's so good it's like the basis of
story time
it wasn't about why fantasy sucks I was
trying to understand why people like
fantasy oh and Casey was talking about
how fantasy sucks he hates it yeah yeah
Casey fantasy has never had Italian food
that was good unless he was in Italy
I feel like the whole reason for fantasy
is is fun because it's the movies that's
the only place you can create it you
know what I mean it's like creating that
world from nothing but just for context
for everybody at the start of Marvel
phase four this is what it is let me say
really quickly okay from January we have
one division then we go to Falcon and
Winter Soldier then we go Loki then we
go Black Widow the movie yeah a lot of
down thumbs up
I thought it was dope I liked it the one
with the with the fat dad right you
couldn't fit in this Cinema let me just
ask you this and maybe this is a stupid
question but for me it's like cool but
what are you guys setting up with this
[ __ ] like for me it's like because
because we're a year and a half out of
this [ __ ] I don't know where the [ __ ]
this shit's going who the big
overarching villain is I knew early on
that Thanos was involved right now I'm
like yo what the [ __ ] is going on it's
like they're [ __ ] products out just
to crank some dollars and just to
generate new characters new action
figures new comic booksake I think it's
too much Marvel content right now
because there's too many shows that's
like I don't watch a handful of them if
I think they're just too much I didn't
even get through the list and we're
already talking about can you tell me
which one's phase one phase two phase
three phase four oh dude where were you
the past 15 minutes not reading a
[ __ ] list to you let's face because
you know straight to phase four and to
grow up what's phase three come on dude
just give it to him
just know that Marvel phase two
this is the beginning and end so we
don't read
beginning to end yeah no so it's like
the beginning movie of phase two or the
end okay okay beginning movie of phase
two is uh Captain America Civil War yeah
oh okay end of phase two is Avengers
Infinity War I see so they they broke up
no they called it at the time uh it's
end game end of phase two is technically
end game right because look they have
Infinity War yeah right here I do feel
like Marvel overwhelmed like already
five years ago yeah yeah like I just am
not looking forward to the next one
anymore like I used to be looking
forward to the next one like you had me
a little
um Infinity war was [ __ ] dope that's
that was Peak to me that was Peak even
end game a lot of ways was kind of like
I didn't get a game as much but I was at
least like looking forward to what's
gonna happen the last things that I said
were actually technically phase three
because what we were looking at in a
poster uh earlier was phase one and two
so it was fake news so we're looking at
fake news we're literally studying
videos end of end game is obviously end
of phase three phase two started at
another time let's just say that that's
what happens what happens when he hopes
to show drunk as fast they say Iron Man
three to Ant-Man Iron Man three to
have you guys tried to go I'm going to
watch it from very beginning to end my
roommate did that really how long did it
take like three days dude they used to
have during the pandemic I did it they
had those midnight showings right where
it's like hey watch all the Marvel ones
before the new Adventure movie now bro
it's a week-long and it's been four
grand yeah
you're like in a movie theater for
[ __ ] two and a half weeks okay okay
One Last Time One Last Time One Last
Time phase one starts with Iron Man and
goes to the first Avengers oh phase two
starts with Iron Man 3 and goes to
Ant-Man which has Avengers Age of Ultron
a random fan between uh phase three
starts the Civil War and goes to
Spider-Man far from home okay and now
phase four started with black widow and
then it's not done yet I like black
widow black widow was cool that was a
pleasant surprise what did you get out
of it it was just like an appreciation
for the character like what I think um
because I don't know what it's Ali
yooping for I like the combined world of
like a dysfunctional family trying to
come together it's like very heartfelt
you know kind of like oh so you just
like did a standalone I like it as a
standalone the movie structure and kind
of like uh even like Guardians of the
Galaxy right like when you just look at
it for what it is it's like each
character almost kind of feels like the
um like a distilled version of like
certain mental health aspects now they
have to come together as a dysfunctional
group kind of like uh what's that guys
in drafts like he's supposed to be the
Asperger's guy or whatever right and
then so is that what he's supposed to be
yeah I think each one is supposed to
like represent this is the add guys the
OCD guys it's the whatever Guy this is
the squirrel guy yeah yeah so the
raccoon what's his character so I like
the uh the the Black Widow where it's
kind of like oh family we haven't met
each other there's a bunch of [ __ ] uh
stuff we need to talk about before we
get over it so I like that combined
World aspect of it cool and honestly
that's awesome but the context of this
for me at least like the way we were
setting this up was like the the current
state of the Marvel Universe like the
phase wise like um you know Shang Chi
happen right yeah what phase is that so
but they that was like a year plus ago
and so like all the stuff they've been
setting up I just don't know where the
[ __ ] it's going and I'm not the new
language or anything but yeah exactly
right but exactly it's just so
disjointed where does Deadpool fall into
all this because I love that it's kind
of floating around in the back floating
until they are able to merge it because
the only problem is the licensing the
licensing he just got boxed so so Fox
got bought and he was part of the fox
licensing yeah because they had that but
he's what like phase two three-ish no
he's not even in the faces at all yeah
he's not so when we talk about the
phases we're specifically talking about
what they call the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the MCU which is when Marvel
Studios as like a production house
started which is why you have things
like tobymacare Spider-Man with with
Sony but that's not part of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
until they partnered which is why they
called uh homecoming because it was
Spider-Man not just Homecoming in like
literally High School home game it was
the Spider-Man franchise
coming back to the yeah when his license
was sold partnered it's still Sony still
Sony's yeah so so then the whole Tom
Holland art all that is a Sony
partnership with Marvel Studios but Sony
basically realized that they screwed the
pooch so [ __ ] hard hey Marvel please
give me to do some [ __ ] they also have
them by the balls in a lot of ways
because they're like oh we cannot sell
we know you [ __ ] need it so you know
come on well let's I will say this
though Andrew Garfield
brought the [ __ ] noise like in the
most recent Spider-Man movie I think he
was the most enjoyable person oh the
whole uh the no way homeboy yeah yeah I
think him is an actor though he's a
crazy [ __ ] fan so that's so that's
like him just like he loved it so much
and he just got paired he got a he got
paired with good writers and like a good
director so he was able to actually
shine which is really cool he also made
significantly the least out of all
Spider-Mans like by far for his two
Spider-Mans I think he made less than a
million dollars that was more evil
Spider-Man I didn't really like those
ones but I did think he redeemed himself
in the way home which Marvel character
do you guys relate with the most blade
what the [ __ ] wait is the tickets blade
is the sickest blade is sick what a
choice I like blade what about blade do
you feel like you uh you are The Thing
from Fantastic Four yeah your [ __ ]
Groot dog actually you're dragged oh
yeah he's dragged yeah you're dry you're
dressed because
you can speak for a while and then
people like oh no what the [ __ ] oh
you're sitting there eating like you're
like
I like blade because black people and
hapito make me happy black people who's
Ryan hasagawa in the Marvel Universe in
the Marvel Universe he's [ __ ]
Nightcrawler dude
Jake Gyllenhall won Jake Gyllenhall
Nightcrawler
Roland X-Men he's cable Cable cable I
can live with cable do you guys know
about cable yeah he's the son of [ __ ]
Cyclops and [ __ ] oh the toys got the
laser eye yeah from the future
that's why he's a time traveler because
he's got a big old gun [ __ ] land what
about JoJo sakawa who's Joe I forget
that pool dude [ __ ] Omega Red
[Laughter]
Joe's probably low-key Joe's Wolverine
is that Loki dude he's low keeper I'm
Silver Samurai dude yeah I'm Silver
Samurai I'm pepper pots because also Joe
seems pretty bi as well
you are low-key wait what's what's the
location Tom Hiddleston he's the brother
of uh Thor he stores the Bible oh that
[ __ ] ear guy in the [ __ ] lawyer
below yeah there you go yeah you're
getting smashed by [ __ ] he's so gay
though
I actually think Loki's one of the
Loki's characters I don't think or act
like that fool yeah you do are you
kidding you don't even watch the [ __ ]
you conniving dictator Joe's like hey
what Star Wars movie did I watch it was
the one with the girl and the guy and
the guy was black and the girl was like
pretty new to being in the Star Wars
movie and I was like yeah you watched
number seven he's like yeah that's the
one I watched I watched number seven
the girl was pretty new
if or he's a uh uh Jeff Goldblum and
Thor Ragnarok oh yeah who's also bi he's
very bi yeah right or something he's
extremely buying that movie you guys
picking the gays characters for me oh
the fires who do you want to be who do
you want to be I like Deadpool man
that's my [ __ ] guy nobody sees you as
Deadpool yeah
I relate with him the most
which part the brain that's like how I
take a uh what Star Wars character are
you the most like test and like I got
Chewie and I was like that sucks and
then I went back and changed some of my
answers and it's like you got Han Solo
and I was like I got Han Solo everybody
thinks I'm Han Solo
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]